même des nues une fois de plus et je me
casse dans le magnéto koh lanta ya la
petite la convainc way j'aimerais bien
participer au jeu et bien vous le dire
ma belle faite aux banques et maintenant
vous partie basile pas fait le jeu peut
participer
ouais mais c'est demain mais à
participer au jeu balle soit de manière
un costume de chauves souris en plus
elle alors les cherry est ce qu ont des
moyens qu'on a mais à mon grand
désespoir parce que j'aime denis
brogniart et je finis mon koh lanta mais
je trouve que c'est une lan chaîne mans
entre la dernière saison et ce nouveau
lieu cette nouvelle saison a été
tellement immédiatemment rapide alors
tendu et en plus on connaît maintenant
le mécanisme de au bout de trois
semaines sur l'île ils sont au bout du
rouleau et donc la moindre notion de
famille à sciences etc
les mets en larmes mais bon hôte du coup
on n'y a même plus d'empathie avec eux
parce qu'on se dit c'est bon c'est quoi
une norme sophie vous regarder koh lanta
pas du tout c'est pas votre kif
non regardez quoi la télé franchement
rien grand chose regardez pas la télé
vous la fais ni cyril bien sûr ça va
changer son spectacle sophie je vais
vous faire une citation je sais pas si
vous la connaissez aimer c'est ce qu'il
ya de plus beau non je regarde des
émissions de reportages démago fouine on
n'est pas couché ardisson a moins
d'émissions politiques là dans les
émissions politiques pour montrer ma
prière sont le journal sur leur vol
spécial were son maire de mes séries
alors on va les séries et les séries
alors là je suis en ce moment je sens
très moyen et marcos pas à rennes
regarde aussi regarder ce week-end un
gardé à vue sauf cas on aurait tous
regardent français regardez ce matin
vers 6h sur une émission politique des
paroles et des repas alors vous vous
aimez kolontar hors jeu très normé non
en fait j'aimais bien koh lanta je
trouve que cette saison est vraiment
effectivement et présentait son tir sur
la longueur c'est juste là sur les
pleureuses en fait c'est toujours quand
même mon sens c'est vrai on est sur les
plus hauts revenus voilà c'est la partie
humaine de koh lanta ont effectivement
on voit on voit comme le dit valérie qui
sont tous au bout du rouleau et moi ça
me touche mais après je peux le koh
lanta de cette année je trouve que c'est
beaucoup moins bien que l'année
précédente il avait la marée noire s'est
pas les pleureuses qui on sait qu'elles
sont à fleur de peau boudin insultant
c'est la cruauté de la séquence mois
qu'ils servent je trouve pas à grand
chose
le fait de certains sont privés de
courrier montre pas et moi je trouve
assez petit manque que ça y est il est
temps que ça se termine ne sais pas je
trouve qu'il ya un peu trop de télé
réalité maintenant on peut aimer pu
assez d'aventuré j'ai mis le format au
début parce qu'ils étaient vraiment seul
il avait faim et c'était très dit
combien fait normaux il y avait beaucoup
d' aventure - choc qui fait c'était
couach island une fois de plus et je me
casse
[Applaudissements]
bush
et parce que 20h25 ça ne faisait vous
payez moitié prix ça c'est comme ça et
là tu as des mosaïques avec ces
conneries tout va mal avec ça c'est qui
revient toujours prêt et mais moi j'aime
bien quand l'état russe comme ça tout ça
ouais enfin le peureux de koh lanta en
lui même je trouve
après je peux comprendre je pense que
c'est quand ils sont loin de comprimés
fatigue
[Musique]